m
[Musique]
je m'appelle jérôme bettencourt je suis
atteint de sclérose en plaques depuis
indigo plus de 20 ans
ça génère pas mal de handicap au
quotidien
j'ai du mal à écrire par exemple j'ai du
mal à parler ça va mais écrire à marcher
à me déplacer dans tous les gestes du
quotidien c'est compliqué pour tous ces
gestes du quotidien qu'il ne peut plus
faire
jérôme a besoin de l'aide de sa femme
sandrine
ils se sont connus au collège et se sont
mariés il y à 25 ans elle est
enseignante lui était commercial
jusqu'en 2010 l'année où la maladie
s'accélère et lui fait perdre son emploi
il se lance alors en indépendant dans la
vente en ligne de pièces
d'électroménager je suis fier les deux
enveloppes
malgré l'aide de sa femme la fatigue
provoquée par la sclérose en plaques
empêche jérôme de consacrer suffisamment
de temps à son activité pour qu'elle
soit rentable
malheureusement cette activité elle me
paraît absolument pas devoir dégager un
salaire et c'est vrai que lâche
l'allocation adulte handicapé pourrait
être un revenu complémentaire auquel
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas droit parce que
je suis parce que je suis mariée le
calcul de l'allocation adulte handicapé
est basé sur les revenus du couple
on ne prend pas en compte le fait que
mon mari ne gagne pas d'argent
le seul revenu qui rentre dans le foyer
c'est le mien on est à deux sur un
salaire donc c'est vrai que dans la vie
de tous les jours c'est il faut faut
l'avoir en tête on peut pas pas se
permettre certaines choses comme on
aurait pu s'y on avait effectivement de
revenus dans le foyer
l'allocation adulte handicapé est une
aide de 900 euros maximum versé aux
personnes qui ne peuvent pas travailler
en raison de leur handicap
son calcul prend en compte les revenus
du conjoint
s'ils gagnent plus de 2200 euros on perd
le droit de toucher cette aide pourrait
ce qu'est ce qui est injuste c'est que
je suis non seulement dépendant de mon
handicap que je n'ai pas choisi je suis
dépendant aussi financièrement de mon
épouse
ça pose ça ne lui pose pas de problème
mais disons que il est clair que pour
l'ego entre guillemets et puis pour le
l'esprit de se sentir bien aussi par
rapport à tout ça que je sois que je
sois qu une personne à part entière
voilà et que je sois pas que je ne fasse
pas partie que d'un
d'un couple finalement
[Musique]
où
l'an dernier jérôme tombe par hasard sur
une pétition en ligne une demande
adressée au sénat pour changer le mode
de calcul de l'allocation adulte
handicapé je moi je signe
d'emblée je vais partager il est
beaucoup de témoignages sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple stéphanie maladie
m'a rendu handicapé et ce mode de calcul
m'a enlevé toute autonomie financière
ça provoque des crises conjugales
fernando mon épouse est handicapé à 80%
faut-il que nous diversion afin qu'elle
ne perde pas son autonomie financière
cécile depuis que je suis marié je vis
exclusivement grâce au salaire de mon
mari je me sentais prisonnière de cette
situation antoine je me suis retrouvé
sans rien ma copine a commencé à me
donner de l'argent pour les courses je
ne pouvais plus vivre comme ça à
dépendre d'elle complètement
j'ai donc décidé de partir on a reçu
beaucoup de témoignages
on a vraiment le sentiment d'une
injustice si je crois qu'en tant que
parlementaire il est de notre rôle de se
pencher sur ce sujet et de réagir face à
ce qui me semble une vraie
incompréhension que ce soit pour nous
mais également de la part des personnes
concernées philippe mouillé a suivi de
près cette pétition sur l'allocation
adulte handicapé le texte a été déposé
sur une plateforme en ligne du sénat un
nouveau dispositif créé en 2020 pour
permettre à n'importe quel citoyen d'y
soumettre un projet s'il recueille cent
mille signatures le sénat s'engage à
s'emparer du sujet j'ai le souvenir que
toutes les semaines on regarder
l'évolution un plus de 1000 plus 3000 +
4 piles et en quelques semaines le
chiffre de 70 mille a été dépassé très
vite le texte atteint le seuil
nécessaire pour la première fois une
pétition va permettre l'inscription d'un
texte à l'ordre du jour du sénat
philippe mouillée est chargé de préparer
son examen
dans un premier temps je suis dans une
démarche d'audition de façon à se forger
une opinion
et lorsque je rédige mon rapport je
prends une position favorable
à cette déco l'égalisation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé et à
partir de là et bien d'un rôle de
rapporteur d'information finalement je
deviens un rapporteur mobilisateur avec
une vraie volonté c'est de faire en
sorte que ce texte de loi soit votée
pour que ça devienne quelques mois plus
tard réalité
[Musique]
l'engagement du sénateur pour
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
c'est en partie forgés dans cette petite
commune des deux sèvres
philippe millet a été maire de
moncoutant pendant près de dix ans c'est
là qu'il s'est lié d'amitié avec le
conseiller municipal christian geffard
l'intrication se passe à un des premiers
qu'on a fait annuler paris n'a durant
faire une dizaine qu'est ce qu'on a fait
concrètement la juste casser la bordure
pour permettre à ce que les fauteuils
puisse passer tranquillement facilement
aller aura traversé les deux élus ont
beaucoup échangé sur l'allocation adulte
handicapé
tous deux sont convaincus qu'il faut des
conjuguer lisez cette aide
aujourd'hui ce calcul prend en
considération les revenus de l'ensemble
du foyer fiscal
donc si vous êtes mariés en
considération les revenus de votre
conjoint le texte que nous proposions
modifie salle de laon tenant compte
uniquement des revenus de la personne
handicapée
et voilà c'est une modification notoire
de façon à ce que ces personnes soient
beaucoup plus autonome ne dépendent pas
des revenus de son conjoint
comment s'est passé le vote du sénat sur
la h20 coût de ce vote s'est plutôt bien
passé je pensais que ça serait plus
difficile mais l'esat est assez facile
de convaincre mes collègues sénateurs
parce qu'on avait des gros arguments de
bons exemples de gens qui vivaient là
difficulté
voilà donc plutôt satisfait du résultat
la parole est à monsieur philippe
mouillera important de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le montant de la
hache est calculée en tenant compte des
revenus du bénéficiaire et de ceux de
son conjoint
lorsqu'il est en couple lesquels ne vaut
que doivent pas dépasser un certain
plafond qui prend par ailleurs en
considération le nombre d'enfants par
conséquent tel bénéficiaires de la hache
qui s'installerait en couple avec
quelqu'un dont les revenus additionné
aux siens dépasserait le plafond
explique ces perdrait le bénéfice de son
allocation les associations de personnes
handicapées appelle cela le prix de
l'amour et c'est pourquoi je vous
habitent mes chers collègues adapté pour
commencer la proposition de loi dans la
rédaction résultant des travaux de la
commission des affaires sociales je
remercie pour votre attention
le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains apportera son soutien au
texte issu de la commission
le groupe écologie solidarité territoire
dr à cette proposition de loi le groupe
rdse votera cette proposition de loi
nous voterons pour ses textes notre
groupe votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
merci je vais trop voir cette
proposition de loi qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient elle est donc
adopté madame la presse soutenu par la
quasi-totalité des groupes politiques
le texte est adopté sans mal par le
sénat contre l'avis du gouvernement
depuis le départ l'exécutif est opposé à
l'aide des conjugale isation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé mais la
partie n'est pas terminée
le sénat a chiffré le coût de la mesure
à 560 millions d'euros une enveloppe
largement sous-estimées aux yeux de
sophie cluzel
la secrétaire d'état aux handicaps c'est
qu'elle n'a pas le beau rôle dans cette
histoire mais elle est formel si l'on
remet en cause le calcul de cette aide
il faudrait le faire pour tous les
autres minima sociaux en france
notre notre loi notre contrainte de
notre pacte social est basé sur la
solidarité conjugale on se doivent
mutuellement de garantir l'un à l'autre
la dignité la vie et la communauté donc
c'est ça la solidarité familiale et
après pour ceux qui ne sont pas
justement en couple il ya la solidarité
nationale qui jours si on touche cette
règle pour un allocation adulte
handicapé pourquoi pas pour le rsa qui
est aussi un minima social et la laouve
loeb serait de plus de 9 milliards
d'euros
comment j'explique à une femme qui
touchent que le rsa que demain elle se
met en couple
et justement cette fiscalité elle
continue à la voir et pas la personne en
situation de handicap
c'est inexplicable donc je pense que
c'est vraiment important à faire passer
comme message
je suis pas une ministre qui veut priver
des personnes de ces droits au contraire
au contraire j'ai octroyé énormément de
droit depuis le début du quinquennat
mais je pense que notre système de
solidarité doit aller à ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin c'est ainsi qu'a été
construit notre système sophie cluzel
compte bien défendre sa position à
l'assemblée nationale car le vote du
sénat n'était qu'une étape
il doit encore être approuvé en deuxième
lecture par les députés
en attendant la fameuse règle défendue
par le gouvernement continue de
provoquer des situations absurdes
elle oblige certains à mentir pour
rester en couple et en enfer me d'autres
dans des relations toxiques
[Musique]
80% des femmes handicapées seraient
victimes de violences physiques et
psychologiques france y en a fait
l'amère expérience
cette jeune femme ne nous donnera pas
son vrai prénom
mais elle a accepté de nous raconter son
histoire j'ai 28 ans et la maladie de
pompe est une maladie neuromusculaire
dégénérative et aujourd'hui je suis en
incapacité de de travailler puisque d'un
jour à l'autre c'est la grande loterie
je peux me réveiller sans pouvoir
marcher correctement avoir besoin de mon
fauteuil roulant bat aujourd'hui pour
pour stabilité
meta en plus d'un traitement lourd qui
se fait uniquement à l'hôpital j'ai
aussi voilà du renforcement musculaire à
faire chez moi ça me permet d'évacuer
beaucoup de tension et psychologique
d'angoise et évacué aussi les
frustrations
[Musique]
21 ans j'ai rencontré le premier amour
de ma vie en amour un peu inespéré parce
que je pensais qu'avec ma pathologie et
toutes ses conséquences
je pourrais jamais vraiment trouvé
l'amour
on s'est installés ensemble l'année
d'après je savais que j'allais perdre en
autonomie financière avec mme nash
allait être moindre et ça a été une
concession à faire et est sur le coup
j'ai accepté parce que ben c'était
l'amour et j'étais naïve
[Musique]
les choses ont dégénéré à partir du
moment où ça a été compliqué pour moi de
participer financièrement à toutes les
dépenses qu'on peut avoir dans une vie
de couple on m'a beaucoup culpabilisé
aussi de mont royal de ne pas pouvoir
travailler
voilà c'est ça a été un peu la descente
aux enfers petit à petit ou ou
psychologiquement j'ai été rabaissée de
manière directe par la famille de mon ex
et je me suis laissé faire et ça a
conduit à des des propos qui ont été de
plus en plus dur notamment sur le fait
que les personnes handicapées comme moi
profitent du système que ça allait pas
pardonné - le mans mais que ça les
faisait chier que leur fils soit avec
quelqu'un comme moi qui bouge pas qui
fait rien
en fait c'était la survie et je me
disais mais comment je vais faire parce
que il faut que je parte mais qui se
commet enfin je vais me retrouver enfin
côté comment je vais y arriver et
comment je vais partir si j'avais eu mon
autonomie financière
ba est ce que je serais parti plus tôt
je sais pas mais en tout cas j'aurai pas
eu autant peur de me retrouver sans rien
ça c'est certain
pour ne pas perdre leur allocation
adulte handicapé beaucoup renoncer à
vivre en couple ou trouve le moyen de
contourner les règles
[Musique]
mou
alors je m'appelle pascal j'ai eu la
folio en 1961 et je suis atteint des
deux membres inférieurs et du membre
supérieur gauche toulouse et on s'est
rencontrés par s'est marié en 81 6 en
outre 86 et depuis on s'est plus quittés
voilà le fait que nos enfants soient
soient autonomes à l'âge de 20 ans ils
sont partis de la maison et du coup ça
faisait qu'avec le l'histoire du plafond
on pêche perdre et lâche
et donc voilà on a fait autrement on a
pris une décision radicale pour pour que
je puisse garder mon autonomie
financière
[Musique]
où
ça c'est l'un l'acte de divorce qui a
été prononcée par le tribunal de grande
instance de niort ce bout de papier
signifie qu'on n'est plus
on vit plus maritalement et que du coup
je vais pouvoir continuer à toucher le
lhc ce qui n'aurait pas été le cas si on
était resté marié
[Musique]
c'est une décision difficile à prendre
parce que bon on s'aime toujours quand
on se marie c'est quand même
important c'est un engagement c'est de
l'amour c'est voilà on a été obligé de
faire comme ça
officiellement divorcés parce qu'elle
n'est plus censé vivre avec sa femme il
est donc louer un autre logement pour ne
pas se faire repérer par la caisse des
allocations familiales
alors ici c'est malheureusement pour la
caf qu'il faut que l'aménagement le
logement pardon soit aménagé donc voilà
c'est un logement qui est qui était
complètement meublés qui est
complètement habitable il n'habite pas
ici mais c'est son adresse officielle
en gros ça me coûte 250 euros par mois
et ça me permet quand même d'avoir les
900 euros de lâches
donc c'est un calcul financier certes
mais c'est surtout pour avoir une
monotonie à moi ma capacité financière à
pouvoir offrir un cadeau à ma compagne à
pouvoir boire un café si j'en ai envie
sans nous demander à personne pour moi
c'est pas la fraude c'est juste
s'adapter à la situation
malheureusement moi si j'ai pu le faire
il ya beaucoup de gens demandent dans
mon cas qui ont pas la capacité ni lui
ni la possibilité de le faire et je je
je trouve que c'est vraiment injuste
quoi et j'ai tellement de de
connaissance à moi qui sont dans la
panade à cause de cette loi que je pense
qu'il faut il faut faire bouger les
lignes quoi c'est le moment est venu
coup
[Musique]
à l'origine de la proposition de loi
pour changer le mode de calcul de
l'allocation adulte handicapé ils y
allaient députés jeanine dubié philippe
mouiller la reçoit aujourd'hui au sénat
ensemble ils préparent le retour du
texte à l'assemblée nationale en
deuxième lecture le gouvernement sera
cette fois en position de force dans un
hémicycle largement dominée par la
république en marche
il faudra des arguments solides pour
faire voter leurs textes français du
sang de loi portant diverses mesures
qu'elle vient justement remettre en
cause le coeur de notre équipe de
solidarité et de redistribution
je sois but rappeler quelques je pense
que c'est fondamental le fait que la
solidarité nationale s'appuie sur la
solidarité familiale pour adapter son
soutien aux personnes précaires
constitue la base même de notre système
social
on a vraiment le déroulé de tous les
arguments qui sont défavorables à la ppl
et en plus elle a doublement porte parce
que elle confond aide sociale et
protection sociale
la hache c'est dans le code de la
sécurité sociale
c'est pas dans le code de l'aide sociale
quant à leur endroit la solidarité
familiale cd principe de l'aide sociale
donc son truc ça tient bon
l'idée c'est de trancher sur la
définition de cette allocation est ce
qu'on est dans une situation d'un minima
social ok quand on peut comprendre des
arguments de la société d'état ou alors
est-ce qu'on est dans une forme de
compensation financière elle y est
finalement un revenu vous ne pouvez pas
percevoir étendez vous êtes très éloigné
de lempaut dans la capacité d'avoir un
emploi et une fois qu'on a tranché cela
est bien ça veut dire que il est normal
dans cette définition que l'on prenne en
compte uniquement la situation de la
personne n'ont pas les revenus de
l'ensemble de son foyer fiscal
c'est le principe de la pension
d'invalidité par exemple parce que
lorsque vous êtes bénéficier de cette
pension d'invalidité et bien on regarde
votre situation personnelle
aucun cas on regarde la situation de
l'ensemble du foie
voilà donc finalement le texte de loi
permet quelque part de trancher sur
cette définition
le travail a été fait au sénat
maintenant c'est le vote à l'assemblée
nationale moi je sais que mon groupe
politique les républicains sera
mobilisée voilà donc comment tu vois par
rapport aux autres groupes politiques
d'opposition
la mobilisation au niveau des
oppositions il n'y a pas de raison que
le vote au change
donc là je pense que maintenant ce qu'il
faut c'est surtout au niveau du couple
la république a marre de la majorité en
fait modem république en marche on
puisse les convaincre de mai mais je
pense que n'aura même pas besoin de
l'école je pense qu'il y en a certains
sont convaincus de l'intérêt de ce texte
et je pense qu'il faut tout en sachant
que moi je sais par thoune oktar les
associations sont mobilisées on devait
rencontrer députés par député dans
chaque circonscription afin de reposer
une question claire c'est oui ou non est
ce que vous êtes nous suivre voilà
[Musique]
nous retrouvons francs si près de
grenoble
[Musique]
bonjour moi enfant tête rencontrer enfin
dans ces échanges francs 6 et kevin font
partie d'un même groupe
né sur les réseaux sociaux leur équipe
tente de coordonner la multitude
d'initiatives individuelles pour créer
un mouvement plus structurée avec une
méthode
le lobbying citoyens du coup tout le
monde à la pièce est au bon sauveur
alors du coup bas grâce au travail de
martine notamment j'ai pu retrouver donc
dans la liste des députés actuels ce qui
était favorable et qui soutenait un
petit peu 7,7 des conjurés alisation
cette ppl et c'est vrai que bon on a une
à une majorité de deux députés parti
socialiste voit la gauche démocratique
et républicaine
aussi pas mal la france insoumise
également et puis je m'en serais
intéressant noté aussi que bas au sein
de la république en marche on a quand
même temps la 11 sur 268 ski qui sont
voilà qui nous soutient qu'ils nous
soutiennent voilà donc là maintenant ça
va être à nous un petit peu de de les
contacter et bien sûr contacter aussi en
priorité députés qui sont à la
commission des affaires sociales donc
l'idée c'est de c'est très simple c'est
d'aller contact et donc nos propres
individuellement les députés nos
circonscriptions pour connaître leur
position est ce qu'ils seront favorables
ou non est ce que l'on a des chances que
ça passe on ne sait pas on espère
évidemment mais il faut mobiliser il
faut que toutes les associations les
citoyens soient derrière pour que les 7
juin ça met la pression à ceux qui
seraient réfractaires encore à cette loi
qui qui paraît aujourd'hui est une
question de bon sens pour convaincre les
députés
ils ont créé un site internet où chacun
est invité à raconter son histoire
du coup là ce matin je vais publier le
témoignage de michel
si je témoigne c'est que depuis fin 2015
je suis atteint d'un cancer du sein
d'emblée métastatique donc pas
guérissable
lorsque je trouve très touchant c'est la
fin là j'espère vivement que nos députés
seront rétablir les choses afin que nous
ne terminons pas notre vie déjà écourté
par la maladie tout ça c'est pareil il
faudrait compromettre le tag l'urgence
l'urgence c'est aussi celle de francs si
elle voudrait vivre avec son compagnon
mais plus question pour elle de perdre
son autonomie financière
c'est une atteinte neurologique et
musculaires qui fait que voilà je sais
que plus le temps passe et plus je vais
perdre en autonomie
donc moi pour moi la situation à
l'urgent parce que moi le temps ce n'est
pas de l'argent mais pour moi le temps
c'est de la vie un mois aujourd'hui
voilà j'ai rencontré j'ai rencontré
l'amour j'ai rencontré quelqu'un de
formidable ci et là au quotidien qui est
là pour les douleurs physiques et pour
les doigts les douleurs psychologiques
j'aimerais pouvoir le jour de mon
mariage pouvoir marcher et et au moins
denses et un tout petit peu pour
profiter de cette journée
ce serait le plus beau jour de ma vie de
pouvoir officialiser avec l'homme avec
qui je partage tant de choses mais pas
encore là les troupes